their clients are considered the most
vulnerable at-risk age group for Cova 19
would you guys consider yourselves on
the front lines of this knowing you are
feeding some of the most vulnerable
potential patients yes I really respect
what first responders do you know they
really have to set aside their own
feelings and emotions and fears to go in
and take care of a patient or a client
and I feel like that's what our staff
does we wrote along with Jennifer Atwood
on her volunteer route this is the part
of the process that's changing the most
how you doing okay when volunteers drop
off these meals they're required to keep
their distance food service has stopped
at community centers across the region
replaced by curbside pickup would you
have food in your house if it wasn't for
these people very little but this helps
a lot is there a level of fear right now
with the uncertainty I think so I think
it's normally we're able to predict how
much it's going to cost and how much
food we're going to need to get through
a certain period of time right now we
don't know I can't stress enough this is
more than just about food it goes way
beyond that it's about a handshake a hug
this social interaction between people
that for some of these seniors come into
a place like this this is all they get
for the day so these organizations are
dreading the point where they will have
to stop all of this to keep people safe
but they are also very much preparing
for it all right Maria thank you yeah
they're doing such good work in it she
said for many people it's all they're
getting at the moment you know social
interaction is so important it's really
it's really everything Maria thanks
again